The cultist screamed.
The long and spindly but unimaginably powerful
arm of the Shy Guy had him by the leg, dragging
him backwards, his fingernails carving deep
ruts into the floor.
His friend was already on the run, but his
death warrant had been sealed by a glance.
In the history of evil plans, rarely has an
evil plan backfired so spectacularly.
As the Shy Guy bellowed, destroying its latest
prey and galloping after the second, which
would soon become the third, and the fourth,
and the fifth, and so much more as the personnel
of the SCP Foundation caught unplanned glimpses
of his terrible face.
it would take a God to undo the chaos that
was unfolding.
The exact same God that these two idiot cultists
were here to destroy.
The plan had seemed so simple, so perfectly
straightforward on paper.
Sneak into the SCP Foundation and assassinate
SCP-343.
That being said, even deluded cultists of
the Scarlet King knew that killing the anomaly
believed to be God himself was going to be
far easier in theory than in practice.
And yet, neither one of this intrepid pair
of Foundation impersonators could ever have
predicted things would go this bad.
Several years earlier, Zachary and Cash, were
nothing more than a pair of social shut-ins
trawling forums on the internet from the secluded
sanctuary of their basements.
In fact, it was on a particular one of these
forums that would lead to the pair eventually
meeting in person: Parawatch, a deep-web online
space for discussions of the supernatural.
While there was nothing inherently insidious
about Parawatch itself, it did draw in those
who were interested in the paranormal and
even the anomalous, like Zach and Cash.
And that made the forum the perfect recruitment
tool for those whose intentions were far more
nefarious.
Both men were individually approached by another
user, who was only known by his screen name
‘C.ot.S.K’.
Over some lengthy conversations with this
mysterious third party, both Zach and Cash
found themselves being convinced into believing
the core tenets of a murderous cult that revered
a conceptual deity: the Children of the Scarlet
King.
And it was during a secret gathering of their
fellow members that Cash and Zach would not
only meet, but find themselves specifically
tasked with a mission that was meant to clear
the way for the Scarlet King to enter our
reality.
Simply put, the two of them were tasked with
killing God.
The plan was devised by one of the longer-standing
Children of the Scarlet King, who divulged
their cult’s knowledge of the SCP Foundation.
Specifically, an entity known as SCP-343,
a powerful reality warper who had claimed
to be the architect of the very universe itself.
In the eyes of the Scarlet King’s followers,
this meant that SCP-343 could pose a direct
threat to the ascension of their destructive
deity.
If the Scarlet King was ever to gain access
to this universe, there was a high chance
SCP-343 could oppose him.
So, with stolen credentials and Foundation
personnel garb, Zach and Cash were sent in
to ‘remove’ SCP-343 from the equation.
It goes without saying that killing a being
believed to be God himself was hardly an easy
goal to achieve.
Nobody could just poison SCP-343, or take
him out using conventional weapons, or even
use any other typical methods of assassination
that would work on a human target.
Instead, Zach and Cash needed to get creative.
Luckily, there was another anomaly kept contained
by the SCP Foundation that the Children of
the Scarlet King had thought would be perfect
for the job.
It was a Miniature Event Horizon, a black
sphere that could pull any nearby matter into
itself.
Anything brought within the vicinity of this
anomalous wormhole would quickly be sucked
in, and ultimately lost forever with no chance
of retrieval.
Sure, it might not kill SCP-343, strictly
speaking, but it could certainly remove him
from play, leaving the universe unprotected
against the rise of the Scarlet King.
However, there was one tiny problem…
one otherwise minute detail that, because
it went uncorrected, jeopardized the whole
plan.
It could have been down to inaccurate information
that the Children of the Scarlet King had
on the SCP Foundation.
After all, the organization was known for
keeping its operations and even its very existence
a closely guarded secret.
Or perhaps, sheerly due to human error, the
wrong number was said by the wrong cultist
at the wrong moment, misheard or misread leading
to a ‘4’ being replaced with a ‘6’.
You see, the Miniature
Event Horizon was designated
as SCP-094, but by mistake, Zach and Cash
had slipped undetected into the Foundation
in search of SCP-096, unaware that anomaly
was far from what they were expecting.
The look of terror on Zach’s face appeared
instantly as the pair of Scarlet King fanatics
opened the door to the containment cell.
That same horrified look had vanished just
as quickly the second that SCP-096 took notice
of the two visitors.
In the blink of an eye,
the abnormally proportioned
humanoid anomaly had gone from being hunched
over in a corner, gently rocking itself, to
standing directly in front of Zach and Cash,
towering over them both and
screeching incoherently.
Cash turned and ran, abandoning his cultist
compatriot as Zach screamed in fear.
The Shy Guy had grabbed him.
A moment later, his screams had been silenced,
thanks to SCP-096.
Cash had no idea what the creature was – all
he knew was it certainly wasn’t the miniaturized
black hole he and Zach had been sent to find.
But he tried to keep the original goal in
mind even in a moment of crisis: take out
SCP-343 so the Scarlet King could rise.
Maybe this other anomaly, whatever it was,
could stand a chance against the reality warper.
Cash would never get to find out, however,
as he was tackled to the group by a Foundation
security team as he turned a corner.
But SCP-096 had been hot on the cultist’s
heels, and had appeared behind him just as
he was being restrained by security officers.
And the whole unit could see the Shy Guy now…
which meant not one of them stood a chance.
Meanwhile, elsewhere in the facility, oblivious
to the carnage of the unfolding containment
beach, SCP-343 was enjoying a stroll around
the Foundation site, with a hamburger in one
hand and a milkshake in the other.
He’d spent most of the afternoon the way
he usually did, phasing out of reality to
an extradimensional astral plane outside of
the known universe where he could privately
enjoy a game of Solitaire using a deck of
cards conjured out of nothingness.
Upon returning, polishing off the dregs of
his lunch, which he’d also willed into existence
from nowhere, SCP-343 barely noticed that
the entire Foundation seemed to be on red
alert.
Or, more accurately, he did notice, he just
didn’t do much to help.
You see, one of the more notable things about
SCP-343 – aside from the fact that he can
use his anomalous abilities to do literally
anything imaginable – is that he very much
enjoys taking a back seat.
He claims that, after creating the universe,
he got tired of having to be in control of
everything, everywhere, all at once.
And so, while SCP-343 could right every wrong
and solve every problem in the entire universe,
he chooses not to, all to pursue the illusion
of giving up control and leaving the universe
to its own devices.
That is, unless something tries to harm him
directly… and something was very much about
to.
While the pair of Scarlet King cultists who
had accidentally set SCP-096 free were already
dead, they’d unknowingly started a chain
reaction.
The Foundation desperately dispatched more
of its personnel to try and re-contain the
Shy Guy, but the more they sent, the more
of them observed the creature.
This gave SCP-096 even more targets, extending
its rage state as it zipped
through the Foundation,
killing everyone that had clapped eyes on
it.
Until that rage-fuelled
rampage led to coincidentally
cross paths with SCP-343, who had just walked
through a wall on his way back to his cell…
right into the path of SCP-096.
“Oh dear, dear me,” SCP-343 sighed, finishing
the remainder of his milkshake before making
the empty cup and straw disappear.
“It’s been some time, hasn’t it, Ian?
My boy, look at what’s become of you.”
For a moment, SCP-096 seemed to pause, its
pale skin flecked with droplets of blood thanks
to the sheer number of guards and researchers
it had torn through for daring to look at
it.
“I see you’re still having the same old
troubles,” the reality warper continued,
reacting eerily, calmly, and casually towards
the towering monster.
“You know, you really ought to work on your
confidence.”
That did it.
The sentence touched a nerve within the Shy
Guy, giving it a pang of sadness that erupted
quickly into an unbridled rage.
It didn’t matter that SCP-343 was a powerful
anomaly with the ability to do almost anything:
he had still looked at SCP-096, in fact, he
was looking directly at it.
And that meant he had to go.
His fate was sealed, as the creature began
wailing and charged straight for SCP-343.
With a casual wave of his hand, God swiped
the creature aside, sending SCP-096 flying.
Thrown telekinetically – much to its surprise
– the creature found itself phasing through
walls as it sailed between corridors and other
containment chambers.
In and out, in and out until it sailed through
the solid steel wall of its own cell, landing
right back in the corner that it had started
in.
But rather than return to crying in a fetal
position as it normally did, SCP-096 got right
back up and raced back through the halls of
the facility, homing in on SCP-343.
Being sent back to its room was enough to
keep the Shy Guy’s rage state active, and
it hadn’t changed the fact that God had
still looked at it, so he had to kill him.
Traveling at anomalous speeds, SCP-096 blinked
into existence right behind SCP-343 as he
sat down and relaxed in his favorite chair.
The horrific humanoid shrieked loudly, although
SCP-343 didn’t turn around to look at it;
he already knew it was there.
He had sensed it even before it left its cell.
With yet another lazy swish of his hand, SCP-343
sent the Shy Guy away.
This time, SCP-096 realized its long legs
seemed to be moving independently, walking
backwards along the exact same steps it had
taken to get into SCP-343’s containment
chamber.
It continued going backwards, and despite
its frustrated attempts to rush back towards
the reality-warping old man, it couldn’t.
Little did the Shy Guy realize it wasn’t
the only one.
SCP-343’s command over the fundamental laws
of the universe was so great that he had altered
time itself.
Everything was now running in reverse, albeit
for a few short moments; birds in the sky
were flying backwards, waterfalls were flowing
upwards, the Earth was spinning in the opposite
direction on its axis.
Everything in existence was like an old VCR
tape being rewound, until SCP-096 found itself
once again back in its cell.
Now the Shy Guy was mad; really, really mad.
The moment SCP-343 allowed time to return
to its normal, forward chronological flow,
SCP-096 once again raced out of its containment
chamber, hunting down the latest person to
have seen its wide-jawed face.
Usually, nothing could stop SCP-096 from catching
up to its target, often killing them without
fail.
But the fact that SCP-343 could so easily
rework the rules of the universe to send it
back to its room made the self-conscious creature
all the more agitated.
And it was only going to get worse and worse.
SCP-096 kept trying, infamously relentless.
But every time, SCP-343 presented some new,
unpredictable way of stopping the Shy Guy
from getting to him.
On one attempt, he caused the creature’s
atoms to rearrange themselves into long strands
the closer it got, effectively turning it
into Shy Guy spaghetti.
During another, SCP-343 actually reworked
the way that sight works across the entire
universe, making it so that on a conceptual
level, he’d technically never looked at
SCP-096 according to this newly redefined
way of seeing things.
Every time, SCP-343 set the Shy Guy back,
but never deterred him.
He kept coming back, that is until…
Bored by the constant back and forth between
them, SCP-343 waited for SCP-096 to arrive
next to him once again.
At that moment, he snapped his fingers, and
the creature stopped in its tracks.
A story filled its mind, the story of a once
normal kid.
This young child had been bullied and ostracised
by other children, made fun of for his appearance.
They became depressed, self-loathing, keeping
away from everyone out of the fear they’d
been taunted.
The child started to hide their face, desperate
that nobody look at them and laugh.
“Listen,” SCP-343 told SCP-096.
There was nothing around them; the universe
had seemingly faded away as the pair stood
in a pocket of space outside of reality.
“Just listen closely.”
Silence.
Not a whisper, not even the creature’s own
breathing could be heard.
“No-one’s laughing at you anymore,”
SCP-343 whispered.
“It’s okay, you can stop now.
There’s nobody left who can hurt you.”
With that, SCP-096’s very reason for being
had ceased.
The Shy Guy didn’t exist anymore, it didn’t
need to.
Restoring the universe to its previous state
with another click of his fingers, SCP-343
was free to sit back in his chair and relax.
There he could continue pretending he wasn’t
in control…
Now go and check out “SCP-343 GOD VS BILL
CIPHER FROM GRAVITY FALLS” and “SCP-096
TALE A LESSON IN POWER” for more!